[Music]
even today I just bought another
business the other day I'd rather buy
businesses help people be successful
it's a lot more fun than just buying
some stocks in the s p 500.
[Music]
what I get excited about is putting in
people in business for themselves I
probably put in close to a thousand
people it's hard to believe that I
bought a franchise we started with two
stores and fifteen hundred dollars and
we built it into 44 States 800 stores
and then I sold that business and then
we moved to Florida started all over
again in the car business bought a
couple of car dealerships and turned
that into 24 dealerships almost a
billion dollar Enterprise they grew up
in a Detroit metro area Blue Collar
family my dad worked in the factory and
dual school buses during the day and my
dad worked two jobs my mom was at home
with six kids in nine years so that was
her main focus and when the kids got out
of the house she went and worked in the
factory to make some extra money people
said why are you so passionate about
small business well that was my American
Dream but biggest reason I'm passionate
because in our case we created close to
four or five thousand jobs and also I'll
just say I chaired our local chamber we
had 2 600 businesses I think in at that
point in time in Sarasota Florida and 90
95 percent or 15 employees or less they
make up close to 95 or 98 percent of the
business enterprises where the tax
writing committee I expect to be the
next chairman hopefully I'm going to do
everything I can to help American
businesses get to the next level whether
it's writing things off quicker or taxes
that make some sense
one thing I will say one of the biggest
challenges and I hope to weigh in a lot
more aggressively is the debt and the
deficit we've gone from you know 10
trillion in debt in the last 20 years to
31 trillion dollars a trillion dollars a
debt a year average that's got to stop
and I'm going to do everything I can to
stop that I don't know there's a typical
day but you know a lot of times it's
just meeting with constituents we're
also working on policy my focus
obviously is big on Ways and Means
Committee tax trade health care so
there's a lot of energy and effort that
goes into that especially right now as
we prepare for the next Congress to take
a look at what we can get off to on a
fast start I want people to realize that
anything's possible but it all starts
right here you got to believe that it's
all about expectation the power of
believing there's a lot of magic in that
that's what's happened to me is have big
goals make sure you're careful about who
your friends are but anything's possible
in America America's special and that's
why I'm doing this fight for our country
I think it's the best place on the
planet but I want to keep it that way we
need to continue to improve where we're
at and that's my goal with this
committee